so we want to dive in a little deeper on
this idea of code reuse and in order to
do so we should really define what we
mean when we say code reuse well when
you're writing software reuse of code is
the practice of writing generalized code
that can be relied upon to address a
variety of different goals now whenever
you notice that two parts of your code
have similarities there's an opportunity
to factor out the similar aspects of it
into some reusable library code so that
you won't have to repeat yourself in
either of the two original places so
here's an example we can use to think
about code reuse imagine you wanted to
write a simple game that involves cars
driving along a street the player is on
the run from a crime syndicate and has
to avoid their goons who drive around in
these unmarked vans our program is going
to need to keep track of a lot of data
about each of the entities moving around
the system and so we'll use
object-oriented techniques a lot here
now that we know what we're shooting for
let's put these mock-ups away and focus
on the code that we're going to write